how to get mad culinary skills the last
og cookbook and of course when you think
of cookbooks you think of Tracy Morgan
you are you are the new Martha Stewart
that well growing up in the heart and
the neighborhoods you had to know how to
get down for your crown so my uncle
fatty love aka Michael he would throw
out all the leftovers and one plot and
called it wild style and that began the
journey he's also called me young
Skywalker in the kitchen young Skywalker
wait how did you get the nickname young
Skywalker in the kitchen god bless I
look like first of all I look like Luke
Skywalker
okay I'm built like layman if I close my
good like Ben Kenobi but we kids would
to get you utensils that's how you slice
slice up cucumbers Chewbacca here's my
shoe box Harry that's his cousin Baca
that's Luba Oulu Baca is chewy yeah but
everybody know chewy was ground chewy is
full of cray fritzy so he was behind on
his child support payments and everybody
knows fritzy fritzy does a pretty good
impersonation of you I want you to grade
I like Rory sparrow and Lou you're I'm a
New York Knick fan somebody gonna get
pregnant at this point Wow
what do you think I'm Brian fellows you
better tell that ostrich stop staring at
me you slow it down a little bit okay
you better tell that bird you stop
staring at me I'm Brian fellows I'm
talking so fast you don't have to sell
me a Cadillac I don't talk that fast see
I'm talking my pace let me hear you talk
with this pace I like the New York
Knicks I like you can't where was you
when the lights went out in 75 I was in
my cell you could tell I was in my
apartment was six years old I was in my
apartment building and in Brooklyn New
York and the brain beach Coney Island
area that's how you could New York where
was you and the lights went out in 75
yeah where was you when the Son of Sam
was running around here I was in Ohio
Wow yeah you know what you had now you
in Rome
I'm in Rome New York on and it said New
York City is wrong baby will you ever
leave here never
how roots and when you cut the tree from
the roots wherever to the tree it does
let me give the hold the official
introduction here the cookbook is a
tie-in to the TBS comedy the last og
starring Tracy Morgan and Tiffany
Haddish I like her yeah she's good she's
good she's good but she's new to the all
it is but she's gonna be good 80 soulful
recipes with street cred the last og
airs Tuesdays at 10:30 Eastern that's
right you know street cred you know what
I made last night for speaking of street
cred okay you wanna know what I made
last I tell you what I mean last night
day okay I made pork and beans and hot
dogs okay right after I finished
watching True Grit that's what he called
me Tracy Morgan aka Rooster Cogburn you
got a lot of nicknames aka ron jeremy
jr. oh really well okay
were you the funniest guy in your
neighborhood drona absolutely in New
York we not talking about the
neighborhood transcended know what and
became New York who's funnier than you
yeah watch your mouth is there anybody
that you go oh boy Richard Roundtree T
compare me to no no that's shaft he
wasn't funny right on I don't they say
he the funniest
but is there a comedian that you went
you know you've got some skills yeah but
he's not with us anymore Richard Pryor
that's the only guy to compare he's the
king we're all just his princes did you
ever meet Richard Pryor yes I met him
when I was on the Martin Lana show and
me Martin went to the comedy store he
was there in a wheelchair at that point
and he signed a piece of paper for me
I'll never forget how I look and it said
Richard Pryor how come he could barely
read his ledger at that point yeah but I
saved that piece of paper for 12 years
then I lost my wallet once but I got it
in my head though I got it Howard look I
got the people the paper yeah I got it
on my head kept it in my wallet like I
have a picture of nipsey Russell yeah in
my wallet
and Lucille Ball and I old - Jackie
Gleason I keep Jackie Gleason with me he
made me wanna do comedy Jackie Gleason
yeah Jackie if you watch the first year
of the lasso Jimmy episode nine me and
Tiffany hands are on a couch talking and
I look at her I go baby you're the
greatest
that's for Jackie Jackie Gleason yeah
and I think Lucille Ball's underrated oh
no no no not she told me physical she
put a hold she had a whole mouth full of
candy in their mouth so that was the
physical and a problem I think some time
with the stand-up the comedy today is
that a lot of people are afraid to take
the pie in the face I'm old school
comedy I'd do anything for laughs I'm
old school you would take a pint when's
the last time you took a pie in the face
last night my wife every time you come
on you you're you get in trouble with
your wife like I'm no different than the
other guy in here what what is bothering
you sports-wise now get like your Knicks
are you okay with I'm good
would you make a bow trade like KP and
Julian all of them yeah and you free up
seven
salary cap yeah that means the Rings are
coming I just have to tell Nick page
Nick our fans be patient
they've been patient a long time yeah I
know but you buy everything when it's
ready we sell no wine before its time I
see I see
could you needy on ice you don't drink
everybody be patient I love fish Dale
Dolan is leaning back like that right
dude a job now
what if Kevin Durant came to you the guy
Kevin is coming
Kyrie is coming and I already spoke to
the government about the ball dropping
so we get in Zion don't worry about it
you are I suppose the government
somebody got paid what if Kevin Durant
said hey sell me on the next this is
this is Rome okay this is Rome you were
in a ring here
Wall Street is right down a block Kevin
wouldn't ring here you can sell all the
Big Macs and Cadillacs you want after
that this is the biggest market in the
world the next could be the last place
we still make the most money in NBA this
is New York City baby Rome doing the
center of the universe what kind of game
do you get Mars I was a point guard
I had the Sham guard down you were God
sham God before God
Jim crushed-up and Chris pause I'll push
right up I gave the sham go to sham God
God sham God's a great shagger reach if
you want to but could you play did you
shoot you anyone be post up I was young
post about I post up and I was a shoot
yeah 24 feet shoe and I could defend
against the pick-and-roll you're old
school oh gee well you don't have truck
Taylor's on right now I still they don't
take my ankles up I'm just putting down
anyway tight I were tight shorts like it
I was like that when I play from the
wall
back in 72 you're there with Alison door
and Oscar Robertson come on graduated
from Pop memorial oh well since I said
POW Memorial yeah but he graduated you
didn't drop down I wish I could go back
to drop nothing what a prayer comes how
about we do a shell comes you going back
to high school
yes I've got listen like I said in that
book that cookbook right there there's a
section of school lunch got to be a
theme for cooking do you want tonight
was school lunch do you want to stick
around I got a little commercial break
here I'm not going no we're doing
he's Tracy Morgan he's the last og check
out the cookbook more with Tracy coming
up and Bubba Watson of course you would
put those two together Tracy Morgan and
Bubba Watson coming up if I told you 30
years ago you'd be pumping out a
cookbook here you would sit in prison
that's what best cooks are they are they
have nothing to do they got number time
to learn how to cook what would they
give them they could make a pot roast
out of a honey bun
yeah but you haven't been to prison have
you never okay well then how'd you
become a good people been to prison okay
I know people have been a prison you
know we were just talking boxing you're
not doing that thing for the zone now
are you an analyst
no I'm represent the zone oh you won't
know what the zoning yes that's in the
pay-per-view yeah and they got a boxer
they got match coming up with Canelo
again shaking a friend yeah John skipper
used to be an ESPN Zone yeah the zone is
good yeah it is less money people don't
want to pay all that kind of money man
how about being a ring announcer I could
do it I could do it but I would rather
be a corner man I could see myself is
Mick I'm gonna yell I'm the black Mick
rocky I'm Ernie if I'm a young girl II
fudge you wanna win do you wanna win son
give me that water down there give me
that water
watch his mouthpiece off come on now
everything
down in his gym come on man I will throw
this wife out this time and if he knows
[ __ ] bundini brown got to gotta throw
punches that corner man sees what you
don't see in the ring fridge he's been
doing his impersonation of Rocky so what
do you think oh yeah he got it this guy
business chicken you're Italian what
about my prime you ain't nobody put Mick
on yeah when he said what about my
primary Mick walked out you chase him I
said he got he got him he let me come in
because when you could I ask you a
question - yeah what was the first words
you heard in The Godfather the very
first words the fur I believe in America
nobody said that the mortician said I
believe in a miracle my office and my
house is based on a godfather same color
and everything I have a mortician coming
every week
hired a mortician to come in once a week
ago can I be your friend Godfather but
this is the day of his daughter's
wedding the day of his daughter's
wedding come on man you can't refuse
yeah you can't he said um you may your
first grandchild be a masculine Grinch I
remember that you don't do slept with
the fishes Luca that's right brass key
but you don't do a Brando impersonation
dude who's your best you got you do not
go to do you do Judge Judy no no I
yeah you do I don't I do original Curtis
okay
impressions include this is this on a
bio here you to me Louis Armstrong yes
Judge Judy bailiff burnt that's but
that's mine Angelou can I say so
then my greatest impression was doctor
says for the plan of the Apes okay the
first night let me close my eyes and
I'll imagine that I'm okay zero and dr.
Zira's this is after he tied them up on
a beach and Taylor drove off with Nova
Nova he rode off on Aldrin and the zero
said what do you think you'll find out
there doctor he said hey destiny Wow you
don't you don't do impressions of any of
these people start you on a regular okay
hey janay the cookbook the last og
cookbook is a tie-in to the TBS comedy
the last og it's Tracy and Tiffany
Haddish and you have the 80 soulful
recipes and street cred inspired by the
show with elements woven throughout that
will immerse readers in the OG universe
the second season of the last og airs
Tuesday at 10:30 Eastern on TBS yeah you
know what this show and people are
gravitating to the show a lot of
people's really great when you shoot it
we shoot it on the streets of Brooklyn
so my show is not a show about the
community my show is a show starving in
the community it's like looking at
Cooley high all over again Cooley high
meat star there are couple The
Honeymooners so the white shadow yeah
he's like Coolidge it was a show about
the community but okay but you growing
up you grew up with some famous people
in the Bronx sure a few I had a few of
them around me in in Brooklyn okay and
the Bronx okay like who okay and just in
my projects alone you have more breelan
it was a great fighter Marvel in the
yeah most Sanford he was a big boys and
girls high school that played d1 okay
these are the people I grew up under
that was my family didn't have line down
Macmillan who is the executive of
Prince's estate and
michael jackson's old lawyer lawndale
Macmillan he's also the editor of The
Source magazine right Big Shot salon
down and I had then I had my dad yeah my
uncles those mom my father was my first
og okay my last one was Jesse funny what
my father was Richard Pryor funny and he
was a musician but what's in James just
like Rick James yeah we called him Rick
Jimmy Jimmy Morgan we call him Rick
Jimmy really mm-hmm
Matt get it from him but what I get from
my mom was her stubbornness she refusing
that her kids go to prom my mom's
refused to take no fun answer and that's
what I am as far as funny and showbiz
I'll be freezing how many people said
it's not conventional stand-up comedy is
not a conventional job I refused to take
no I'm funny I'm funny like my dad was
jay-z and your your uh neighbor jay-z my
effect Dre jay-z go right across the
street
biggie smalls little Kim little C's we
all come from best I do a DA take the
girl killer guy that's where I'm from
and Michael Jackson Michael Jordan was
born in Brooklyn Hospital right down the
block
yeah but you can't really take credit
for that yeah why not
where was he born Brooklyn Brooklyn but
you can't say boy Michael is part of the
great basketball tradition of New York
no you wait yeah
that's what I say I don't think LeBron
ever be better than join cuz you don't
got a FRU game I can show you a double
nickel or Christmas II do you feed but
wait a minute day I could show you
Willis Reed limping out the tub that's a
fruit game I did comedy a hundred or one
fever that's a fruit game Wow
I'm great wet your fever was all the way
hundred fever still no at Carnegie Hall
do you think that Jordan maybe didn't
have the flu he was hungover nah I don't
think he drank I don't think he drinks
that's Michael Jordan it's a better
story if he has the flu I'd yeah Jordan
drinks milk no it's Michael Jackson
there's a picture of Michael Jackson
glass arse us studio 54 you seen it did
you ever go I was too young
how did this studio 54 but I think I was
inside of my father at the time you were
your dad when he was Rick James before
Rick James yeah we call him Rick Jimmy
yeah super freaky my mother called him a
witty BTW big bog freak and that means
one cuz look at Tracy what was your
first paid stand-up gig
give me the first time I started
thinking outside the box with that
uptown comedy club I think I got $75 how
old is $75 of maybe 21 22 then I got our
def jam but then again you gotta
understand four months out of the
workshop I was on Def Jam that's four
months at that one to the workshop I was
already on Def Jam that don't happen for
everybody
I don't even come from this planet I
come on platinum Krypton you never a
planet called Krypton do you remember
your man was a skater no oh no green
rock he's scared of Louis no he was
scared of Louis yeah do you remember
your first comedy set yo the first time
I told a joke I was like four years old
sitting on my father's lap no I don't
know when you did it professionally yeah
not yeah that was a comedy club but what
do you do you remember any of y'all
don't remember that that was 30 it's a
go know 30 years ago I know it's funny
what's your go-to joke yeah kids say
don't air oh you can know my sex okay DX
is the funniest thing in the world we
just take it too serious but if you look
at it we look hilarious hilarious we
look bugged out we make bugged-out
noises we we're weird we laugh when we
see two dogs humping
imagine what dogs think watching like
look at Julia why here we look weird
I've told you not weird
did you we're talking to Tracy Morgan
look at us I know that don't look
nothing like porno because it looks so
smooth when they do it right but what we
doing what is so coral clumsy and people
stop and say wait a minute I can't
breathe stop mom I got a cramp wait a
minute I'm cramping up move move oh the
thing you say to each other
I'm glad you cleaned it up for me there
thank you but my neck my neck wait a
minute wait a minute something burning
that pot roast is burnt I got a brisket
honey bun damn kids
how many kids you or the books Eddie's
got trying to break Gandhi's record I'm
almost close to arm Bob Marley really
yeah I mean tell me kiss Bob guy 12:18
really yeah you got some work to do now
yeah I'm on the street street started
good girls bad I'm on them streets
turning on good girls bad what's the you
know we were talking about Mike Tyson
this was during the commercial break and
you think that Mike Tyson things changed
when he fought Mitch blood green so
Mitch was the first one to take him 12
did you how many fights did you see that
Tyson [ __ ] did you go to many and Prasad
missed one cuz I went to get something
to drink which one was that the one in
Atlantic City you go to that bathroom
you gonna miss his fight that's young
Mike you might know Mike was fine yeah
if you went to the bathroom it was a
good chance you go mr. fight what I miss
what is over I went to see when he
fought Joe Frazier's son that well that
didn't look good and Michael Spinks I
went to see that one that one didn't
last long either like when you you can
see it's rare when you see fear on
somebody's face you see it but I saw
fear in those men I was home you was at
the fight yo soy yeah I said this man
should be fighting but but if it went
past the third round Mike started to get
a little nervous
well I don't know if he got nervous cuz
he was already you know like a machine
well everything ended in the first or
second round um when he fought Mitch
blood green he really believed he was
the greatest man in the world you know
that yeah there and then Mitch took him
12 rounds and that's when a boxer
community said wait a minute wait a
minute and then with in Tokyo that man's
mom had just passed away in Buster's and
once you determine can nothing once
somebody's determined to get you they
gonna get you did you hang out with
Tyson at all
no no I'm friends with him now I've
worked with him okay I work with him
Annie from Brooklyn yeah but I remember
Marlon bringing him to my projects
before he became Mike Tyson Mark had
just won the Olympic gold in 94 and he
brought a young Mike Tyson nobody knew
he was everybody's in mom so I saw Mike
before he came Mike Tyson and then he
grew up in Bensonhurst didn't he know he
grew up in Brownsville and I haven't
written both from Brownsville
I'm from bed-stuy I don't go to
Brownsville house real is rough well
what would they do to you in Brownsville
its door refrigerator do to you a
Brownsville that's not going to course
mother Gaston Gaston is the street over
there man
you're Tracy Morgan don't matter that
don't matter they throw a frigid Tracy
Morgan yeah if you wore that watch I'm
not if I was if I wore this watch what
blow it Anthony I'll be a probably no
I'm not just not wearing it
I know I'm not coming back with it would
you just hand it over soon as you're
doing that the show is the last og and
it's Tracy Morgan with Tiffany Haddish
and check out the cookbook the last og
cookbook check out the zone and does own
also because you got the fight mr.
boxing you got Canelo vs. Jacobs right
yep yeah
that's good that's big-time stuff and
that's Saturday yeah yeah let me go
fight a lot of boxing boxing boxing is
becoming prominent again look ma growing
up no but I watch it I brung more
breelan so he got our attention all the
kids next time you gotta fight I was 17
yep 50 now is that when I got in a fight
with my wife I lost what happened she
hit me one time with a frying pan and my
son was right there go he said Down Goes
Frazier goes Frank is your wife
undefeated my wife is undefeated we
don't we don't physically what we argue
she wins happy wife happy life here you
go the last og cookbook he's Tracy
Morgan great to see you thank you glad
you're going well thank always great to
see all right four more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on be our live
or download the Dan Patrick show app